my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys and
i live
in paradise it's funny with everybody in
these boxes i actually feel like i'm at
that like moment in a video game where
i'm selecting my character uh and i'm
just not sure
who i want to go i'm gonna go with that
which avatar will you pick eric which of
us will you choose as your skin
i don't know i don't know where i'm
going but i'm gonna i'm gonna try to
pick everyone here um you know love the
film it's a blast uh one of my favorite
things about it is this concept of
getting to meet a video game character
and that character getting to know you
and developing a crush on you and so
that's actually my first question for
everyone and we'll go around fast but
like if you got to meet a video game
character and and you get to know each
other who would that character be ryan
i'm going to start with you oh god if i
could get to know a video game character
um
oh boy i mean i you know i'm i'm not
going to give you a satisfying answer
here i from the as early as i could
remember i had a thing for miss pac-man
which i i shouldn't i realized that
there's
nothing anthropomorphic about that that
character but um
yeah i just i don't know i always loved
how hungry she was
just talking
yeah just just jody what about you
again mine's not going to be a
satisfying answer but i would have to
just say mario and luigi because i feel
like i've spent the most time with those
guys
in you know and within my own life so i
would like to get to know them a little
bit more on a personal level
little rel i'm coming up to you what's
up uh it's gonna sound very random but
scorpion for mortal kombat whoa i'm
fascinated by that because it's it's the
you know like the outfit is so unique
and they got the scorpion coming out i
don't know what like that's somebody i
feel like i want to hang out with just
in case i have some beef about yo
nice
i like it
joe what about you man i guess going
probably have to be star fox you guys
know star fox anyone know that video
game yeah this old n64 video game i
really loved that whole group of
characters there's like a rabbit and
like a fox and they all were like these
you know i had this team where they
would i it'd be great to sort of break
into that crowd i think i think
for most of people my age princess
toadstool was our first crush so it'd be
nice to hang out with her wow have an
opportunity to save her
be you know be the knight in shining
armor she needs i i think that would be
great uh i'll go nathan drake from
uncharted feels like a fun guy to hang
with and grab a beer with uh you know
ryan uh this is your your second video
game movie of of late uh that has been
received very favorably uh pikachu and
now free guy and so are you actually on
like this larger quest to rescue the
video game movie from the rotten halls
of rotten tomatoes wow uh why why this
century in video game movies well you
know look for starters i'll say that you
know
free guy is about as much a video game
movie as as you know field of dreams
would be a baseball movie you know i
mean it's it's it's we're not actually
based on a video game so it's sort of
hard to
you know to to put it in that category
of a video game movie you know a lot of
people are saying it's the best video
game movie ever made and i've heard that
a bunch of times but i'm like it's a
little bit damning it with faint praise
it's just the movie itself is like it's
it's multitudes i mean it's a romantic
comedy it's an action movie it's an
adventure movie it's wish fulfillment
it's you know it's it deals with a lot
of things like that i think people are
going through right now you know
stepping out of the background and being
and allowing yourself to feel and be
seen what attracted me to the movies had
nothing to do with video games i loved
the world i loved the character i loved
sean levy i wanted like i wanted to just
experience that and and really kind of
immerse myself into that world so jody
uh love your character especially the
juxtaposition of being sort of this
badass intellectual while also being a
badass action heroine uh who also loves
mariah carey's fantasy
and that's actually my question is when
you're being a badass in real life uh is
there an anthem that you sort of have
on the tip of your tongue at all times
i think for me like i have such a strong
affiliation with bruce springsteen
like so it would honestly
it would be
probably like a born to ron would get me
in them would get me in the mood of
feeling a badass
although on set when i was trying to
channel my inner molotov girl
um we channeled beyonce right sean we
would we would blast beyonce um little
rel uh you play the best friend to uh
guy in this movie you are a great friend
in the video game you also have really
cool friends in real life and so my
question to you is what is your best
advice for best friends i guess really
it's just listen to them you know what i
mean i think that's the best skills that
you can have as a best friend is to
actually be able to just listen
sometimes i think
sometimes people give too much advice
and sometimes like i mean i i consider
myself a good friend but i've learned to
just have a good ear and all my best
friends that i love to deaf they they
usually just know how to just let me
vent and without just throwing out an
opinion for no reason
uh joe and uh
and also sean um you know i what was
sort of more difficult here was it sort
of learning the behind the scenes of
making video games and who these guys
are these developers the people that
maintain them and being authentic to
that uh was it acting opposite a
completely unhinged tyco with td which
was the
the more difficult task uh for you guys
uh utkar should go with you uh my most
difficult task was wearing a bunny suit
this was a pretty easy job for me
working opposite taika you kind of just
let him go i mean he's a genius and it
was an honor like i mean you're working
with a hero so i was super lucky uh but
the bunny suit was very tight and it
didn't breathe well
the uh the cop uniform was borderline
stripper level tight
and so that i think
again the breathability
uh of that uniform was maybe not the
that was probably the toughest thing i
mean
i'm kind of mirroring what you just said
at karsh but working obviously with
utkarsh
love you
um and then
or i guess i can't start and then
working with uh working with uh taika
was uh
he is a machine i mean it's like he has
been touched with like the robin
williams gift of just having this
relentless energy and flow and stream of
ideas so
working with him was just like uh
yeah definitely dream dream level yeah
and then sean i would love to just hear
uh a little from you you know the
question we actually had for you is that
when i walked out of here i wanted to
play this game uh did you ever think
about developing the
video game yes it was great because i
didn't have to be loyal to anything but
our own inventions we got to invent our
own video game free city and ironically
the only reason we didn't make the video
game of the game in our movie is we
didn't think we'd have enough time
before the release of the movie had we
known that our movie would be this long
delayed we absolutely could have done it
so uh so that might have been an
opportunity lost but still very fun to
bring this brand new world to the screen
nope
[Applause]
i can't die
i'm never gonna die
[Music]